公園でロウさんスライダーした動画があったんですけども
あの動画ちょっと訳ありで非公開になりました
たまだ見てない方ごめんなさいもう右ことはできませんこれでもう
まあいろいろあったんですよ説明すると長くなるんですけどず色々あってダメという
ことになって非公開になりますまあ公園でねああいうことして危ないからね駄目だ見
てる人も多いし
やっぱこういろんなことに僕もこれから家を使って動画を撮っていかなきゃいけません
道でマジ
ね頑張ったんだけどやっぱりみんなねマネしちゃうからさ
マネしちゃってき月されても困るからねだからみんなあんまりマネしないでね変な事を
たまにするかもしれないけどまあまあでしちゃダメだ今回で反省しました危ないことは
ねいいでやろう俳優で今日ですねこちら2へを4本準備しました
東俺んちの ca ばあちゃんも使ってたナッツぐはぁっ
飛んでいくんだこいつ会があるんですけど英語外なんですよ準備したかといいまず
と夏ってさぁ熱いじゃないですね床が末で海とか話して言うとすごい熱くて熱くて歩け
ないし那覇花ついてアンチってなる理由
俺なんてサイトはそのあっちちを対策することを考えました納本チビ著者を受けこの
よう使うですね
今日
は4足方向をしようと思いますイメージとしては作って二つお付けしますとこうね足僕
はね頑張ってキャプテンとデブをくっつけます
出ても close んで
バーンで行くと思うな音だめちゃクロス雲みたいな顔見たい事項4速で熱い地面から
当院高い日から考案けどあっさり買えるんじゃねーかとぼくは考えたわけなんですよ
天才だろいつもコーナー考えること考えること全てが
点差の4位
していた
1区内ポッチャマはいかないぞ
5弱し完成ですなんかでいっぱいとパンのできそうだ
歩けないスキー場みたいになっちゃってカメラの位置をあげなきゃ
pandan
me
では行きましょうツリー2
[音楽]
腕の負担日間思いな誓い4つの視点のも0に行ける雰囲気
これで終わりと思ったらお前ローマ字 by 大逆転の発想ということを知っている
だろうか
俺みたいな政策客船ますそう杖を逆に床に固定しで杖起きませんてあります百姓の歯
そのものを立てる中古にそれが立つだけで4速箱
方向はいけないけど4方向じゃないなあと写真 nasa はてきたんです熱烈この前
に立てば成功ということで
いきます three two one ではいやいやいや以降ほぼこのコーンっ
けっここぼふっ com
こんなんっ
この後はためは言えないと思う
杏に結論入ったああ
立っ